trong khạt đến là vụ việc viva huy trẻ dịch tốn nhất,
Trung Hoặc của Thông Nam,
Hai Nhi của Trong Ngay Sau,
Sài Giá tại dệnh Thì của Trường Trung Hoặc của Thông Truyên Tương Quán,
có tin chất,
đặc biệt nghiệp chạp,
đặc biệt thống nhất trong những lãnh giá là như thế.
Tây cũng là lãnh giá của các cơ quan trình anh,
và hơi ở biệt tính em mấy công bàn của kỳ thi,
và tạm đồng rất thương cửc,
đến huy tín của ngày giao dục và đồng gà,
và nhìn tín của xa hộ của người rất đối với công đàn,
tổ chất tín,
để là cái điểm lộn điện của người anh,
sẽ thống nhận,
đến gà như vậy.
Hơi Hai để của đủ cơ sờ mà sửi vụ việc của Hect Luung pháp loại,
khách quan nghiêm mình,
đi về sự lý,
phải đảm bảo,
và khi mình tạm xói tinh em,
đặc biệt sắc mình chây đủ,
khách quan bản chất của người phía,
bảo làm công bàn,
công khai,
thống của người đủ pháp loại,
thứ hai,
đặc biệt sửi nghiêm mình,
các tổ chất khán nhân của xa hợp thống của người,
thứ ba,
phương áng sửi nền thân,
phải thác thông quen,
và phải thác của người dễ thị,
và quy định của pháp loại có liên qua,
bảo làm những văn trong góc,
quyền lợp chính thàn,
hợp pháp của các thý xin,
thác quy định,
đồng thời và giữ nghiêm kỳ cơm bản và quy định của kỳ thi,